how are we supposed to beat this thing
we need a plan Knuckles use your
strength to jump off the plane wow okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two I have no idea
[Music]
does it do anything or just stand there
looking ugly
[Music]
like a blister he keeps coming back
he's on the okay to kill this shoot the
missiles make a decision uh I just need
a moment sir I'm trying to figure out
how to do this did you even glance at
Emmanuel
I'll do it
I'm pardon my lightning you might want
to
grab that oh I'm Gonna Pop That Thing
open like a can of children
[Music]
close one
foreign
I felt that
[Music]
what
just happened it's the stash Masher
right here in the manual
Return to Sender
Stone
oh great next thing you know there'll be
a report about a hostile work
environment